was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut meine stimme ist
noch ein bisschen rau weil ich gerade
erst aufgestanden bin also eben und noch
nicht so viel geredet habe ich habe mir
das hier hat man nicht auf jeden fall
machen wir heute was ziemlich cooles
viele von euch können sich
wahrscheinlich an die videos erinnern
ich glaube das waren 2 ich kaufe das
teuerste produkt das war einmal so ein
sessel massagestuhl für über 2.000 euro
oder ich glaube knapp 2000 euro
der nie angekommen ist irgendwann habe
ich das geld wieder bekommen und dann
noch der autor iglu hier auf jeden fall
mal ein foto ein gebinde für etwas über
1000 euro
es waren auf jeden fall alles videos die
mir sehr viel spaß gemacht haben und da
dachte ich mir warum mache ich das nicht
nochmal deswegen an dieser stelle schon
mal wenn ihr bock drauf habt dass ich
auch noch mal das teuerste produkt
ermittelt da gibt es bestimmt wieder
neues zeug lasst mir ein bäumchen nach
oben da aber heute machen wir das
erstmal auf amazon das ding ist auf
amazon gibt es so viele verschiedene
produkte und so viele verschiedene
kategorien
es ist extrem schwer dort irgendwie das
teuerste produkt rauszufinden und falls
man es findet wird es wahrscheinlich
auch über 10.000 euro kosten das gute
ist nämlich bei amazon wenn ich etwas
bestelle das kommt am nächsten oder
übernächsten tag an
bayerisch hätte ich wieder einen monat
oder mehr erwarten müssen da habe ich
gerade keinen bock drauf aber wie gesagt
ich kann das zelt noch mal machen
formation haben wir nur leider das
problem es ist extrem schwer irgendwie
das teuerste zu finden was dann auch
noch lustig ist es soll ja auch lustig
fürs video sein es gibt so viele
verschiedene kategorien und diesen
suchalgorithmus checke ich nicht ganz
weswegen ich mir gedacht habt ihr könnt
mir auf instagram suchbegriffe sagen die
tippe ich dann oben ein und bestellt
dann davon hat das teuerste weil das
kann man dann so filtern und lockt das
habe auf jeden fall sehr viele von euch
gemacht und ich würde sagen da suchen
wir jetzt mal eins von raus und schauen
dann was wir heute bestellen und testen
werden und das coole ist ja dann halt
auch ich kann das öfter machen und mit
weiteren wörtern so und ich glaube das
werden eigentlich ganz lustige videos
bestellen wir einfach mal das teuerste
aus der kategorie gadgets oder gadget
wie auch immer übrigens an die die mal
fragen warum ihr peter steht so heißt
mein vater und ich habe irgendwie keinen
eigenen amazon account glauben noch
immer
also wir geben hier einfach mal gadget
ein und gehen aufsuchen gadget okay juli
das ist ganz wichtig das müssen wir
schon mal anklicken es dürfen nur prime
produkte sein weil sonst gibt es einfach
auch viel zu viel
auch sonst wo irgendwelche händler aus
china die auch in amazon händler konto
haben und dann musst du trotzdem einen
monat auf dein produkt warten da habe
ich keinen bock drauf deswegen nur prime
produkte und hier kann man jetzt schon
auf über 200 euro also es gibt auf jeden
fall eine menge gadgets für über 200
euro und das klicken wir jetzt mal an ok
dann schauen wir mal
ich muss eigentlich sagen hier diese
gesponserten sachen würde ich auch nicht
mitzählen weil das sind manchmal halt
eigentlich keine gadgets keinen plan was
das ist vorbei dass ich eigentlich ganz
cool aus vielleicht nämlich doch
gravierend weil dann kannst du auf
verschiedene sachen dass da in seinem
logo gravierend so was könnte ich all
das macht bestimmt spaß oder wobei wir
schauen wir weiter was gibt es denn hier
noch was ist das denn jogi combo 2.0
smart location smart home
das hier ist noch teurer 299 tragbaren
mini cnc lasergravur werkzeug alter
solche sachen ich finde also auf sowas
hätte ich halt megabad com ab wie geil
du kannst halt überall so danach und du
kannst es ist dass die partie soll das
dann funktioniert das so dass das ist
wirklich so ein mini laser so was habe
ich noch nie gesehen und dann kann man
verschiedene sachen damit alter easy to
use okay da ja das will ich haben ich
hoffe dass es das teuerste warte mal
dann haben wir hier noch weitere sachen
nicht immer weiter runter
de'longhi luftreinigung apparat okay das
ist weg das hier zum glück günstiger das
ist auch alles günstiger hier haben wir
noch einen google thermostat okay noch
eine gravur maschine okay diese gravur
maschine kostet 99 cent mehr
hmm also eigentlich muss ich ja wirklich
das teuerste bestellen
wobei die hat nicht so gut rezensionen
und wenn wir dann noch weiter runter
scrollen waren das leider schon alle
gadgets alle produkte der kategorie
gadgets die dann halt zu den teuersten
zielen und jetzt schaue ich mal welches
wirklich das teuerste werk
ich glaube eigentlich hier diese two
trees lasergravur maschine aber wir
haben hier so ein mini cmc laser für 99
cent weniger und irgendwie finde ich den
viel cooler
ich hoffe das ist jetzt einmal okay wenn
wir sagen wir bestellen den hier und ich
würde mal sagen der hat extrem geil
rezensionen viereinhalb
und da ja wie geil alter du kannst dann
auf dem handy irgend so ein muster
machen und das irgendwo drauf laser
junge das wird geil den will ich testen
und deswegen kaufe ich den jetzt er
kommt auch schon morgen an das ist
extrem geil und eure aufgabe ist schon
bald weitere kategorien wo ich das das
nächste mal machen soll auf amazon jetzt
in die kommentare zu schreiben leute und
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns gleich
wieder wenn das produkt da ist letzter
die denken gegen wir schon nicht fangen
die das haus haben sollte was geht paket
ist angekommen hier zuweilen eltern und
ich bin auf jeden fall wir haben in der
beratung so ein bisschen schlauer
ich hoffe einfach mal das geht nicht
nach hinten los bei meinem talent das
paket ist eigentlich ziemlich klein aber
gut ist es auf dem mini laser ich habe
mir gerade das chinesische werbevideo
dazu gegeben
wir machen hier einfach mal so 300 euro
gekostet
noch besser ok hier steht drauf der cast
away at that you happy with you don't
know how to express fahrt happiness
alles klar also ich hab jetzt zu neuen
laser und ich bin happy
if you don't wait for decades mein
regisseur account you can drive away
download monitor ist alles okay das ist
wahrscheinlich die app die ich brauche
und dann haben wir hier das gerät der
geräte laser pack steht oben drauf und
den mache ich jetzt mal oder ist aber
doppelt und reich auf eingepackt okay
ein lineal aber schon mal dabei und hier
haben wir zu üben okay hier kann man
dann schon drauf lesern
du kannst ja eigentlich auch alles
mögliche laser das sollte ja irgendwie
im werbevideo hat sich mit dem laser
kekse signier tier haben wir den mini
laser hier haben wir das stativ dafür
ich würde sagen ich bin jetzt einfach
mal zusammen und wir sehen uns gleich
wieder
und natürlich auch ganz wichtig die
brille ja das ist gefährlich leute
damit ist nicht zu spaßen eigentlich ich
muss sagen okay eigentlich habe ich das
ganze nur grob wegen dieser mega
stylischen brille junge wie nice alter
das licht sich jetzt komplett grün aus
ladies was geht
die brille sieht doch gar nicht so
verkehrt aus dann kann man sich doch
schon im vorlauf mit blicken lassen oder
das läuft was läuft das haben wir schon
oft steht wie eine eins
hier ist das kabel ok meine eltern sind
gerade im urlaub dass wir nicht so nice
wenn die wiederkommen und irgendwas im
tisch graviertes deswegen verlagern wir
uns jetzt schnell mal in die garage bis
gleich heute ist sie aber auch hier watt
leuchte was geht herzlich willkommen aus
meiner hobbywerkstatt hier wirklich
immer den ganzen tag wenn ich keine
youtube-videos trier gerade laser ist
aufgebaut eingerichtet und wir probieren
jetzt mal aus mit toastbrot eine mini
iphone einem und kitkat weil eigentlich
kann man auf alles laser ich würde sagen
wir starten mal klassisch mit dem
toastbrot und gravierender alex wie
drauf oder das muss ja funktionieren
ich bin jetzt echt mal gespannt jetzt
kann ich hier eine größe eingeben ich
nehme einfach mal das größte weiter
bestätigen jetzt muss ich ihr ein
passwort eingeben
auch an die unter 18-jährigen macht
keine faxen damit das kann wirklich also
andere unterhalten würde ich jetzt nicht
und materialauswahl nach so ok
eigentlich davon im recycling papier
wellpappe leder bambus holz kork also
toastbrot sehe ich jetzt gar nicht
deswegen nehmen wir einfach mal
benutzerdefiniert let's go dann mache
jetzt mal was schickes aus meinem
toastbrot ich finde ich das hier mal mit
mit meinem iphone
jetzt macht einmal schön alex wiederum
dann wird das toastbrot gleich viel viel
lärm ist es gerade noch aus der bereich
wird aus gemessen
egal was machst du jetzt starte mal also
ich glaube dass wir doch nichts mehr
zwei minuten ist jetzt schon hier
zugange während der jetzt hier irgendwie
faxen macht kann ich euch schon mal das
mini iphone jetzt zeigen das hatte ich
noch um fliegen das ist ein mini handy
und hier steht allerdings nicht iphone
drauf hier könnt ihr das sehen da steht
irgendwie sei es drauf oder so und ich
dachte mir das geht natürlich nicht
deswegen machen wir ja auf jeden fall
schon mal gleich das apple logo drauf
ich galt später also okay jetzt geht das
irgendwie ne scheiße leute ihr sitzt ja
wahrscheinlich gefallen
das problem ist bei dem toastbrot
funktioniert das leider nicht viele
vereine die sich mit so etwas auskennen
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen du
idiot ist so klar
ich weiß nicht warum genau aber leute
ich habe mir jetzt das apple logo auf
mein iphone gezogen und das wird jetzt
hier auf meinem feld mini-iphone drauf
gelegen sagt gerichts prüfen
naja ok vorsicht und action passiert
natürlich versucht das würde heute also
irgendwie ist da gar nichts passiert wir
testen das nochmal den vorstößen der
oberfläche liegt würden die zu blind
zwischen den christen das sind aber
warum sollte es beim tuspo nicht
hinkriegen
wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal dass hier
was ist denn daran so schwer
jetzt mache ich doch mal was rein und
dummes ding hier auf dem tisch geht es
jetzt wieder das liegt an materialien
meister
da nicht so wichtig überhaupt nicht was
er vorhat emi war junge leute ich habe
keinen plan dass seine mission ist
irgendwie fällt das ding total rein also
apple logo klappte sollen apple logo
werden ach so ja gut
aha doch das wird erst jetzt tätig ist
jetzt stelle ich das hier oben ist von
ostblock vom apfel deutlich war kann
auch einen letzten versuch nicht dass
das jetzt mal komplett durchlaufen das
dauert halt wirklich so zehn minuten bis
ein kleines mini apple logo auf dem
linken drauf ist aber ich glaube hier
kommt die szene ich denke man wird
wieder nichts sehen der laser wird nur
funktionieren weil so sachen wie holz
wellpappe ich habe jetzt gerade mal auf
eine kartoffel geholt da wir das auch
klappen bei dem toastbrot hier hat das
auch überhaupt nicht funktioniert oder
ist ja irgendwas drin
ich glaube nicht das finde ich ein
bisschen schade weil im werbevideo von
dem ding haben die eigentlich auf alles
gelasert ganz minimal gewalt ist aber
ich glaube man sieht nichts man ey ich
wollte doch einfach nur ein iphone
machen
fast 300 euro kostet mein freund würde
ich das mal durchlaufen wir sehen uns
gleich wieder
hey leute das ist so schade ich glaube
ich es wieder ist hier jeden was drin
das ist lauwarm jetzt aber funktioniert
nicht so egal nächster versuch bei der
kartoffel hier kommt da schreibe ich
jetzt von meinem namen drauf das muss
aber funktionieren lasergravur starten
metzger alter das ich trinke aber ich
schreibe gerade auf eine kartoffel
meinen namen aber auch dass floppt
anscheinende oder wales v ja also so
ganz schön sieht das nicht aus sollte
also mit viel fantasie kann man erkennen
dass das alex wie heißen soll
mal gucken was passiert wenn ich das
jetzt auf malle
dafür müsste das erst mal liegen bleiben
ihr könnt es glaube ich sehen will ist
nichts zu sehen also auch bei dem ein
flop das jetzt versuche ich immer noch
das kit kat aber jetzt mal hier
aha plötzlich funktioniert oder wie also
schokolade ist möglich und das riecht
auch ganz gut nach geschmolzener
schokolade hier steht jetzt gleich nicht
mehr hashtag mai break sondern hashtag
alex wie schaut's euch leute wunderschön
kann man natürlich wieder perfekt
erkennt also das einzige was jetzt noch
machen werde
ich werde auf diesem tisch weil das ist
mein alter kindertisch den habe ich
schon seitdem ich lebe werde ich drauf
schreiben
dieser tisch gehört alex und dann reicht
es auch also ich bin ein bisschen
enttäuscht ich habe mir das viel
lustiger vorgestellt vielleicht könnt
ihr sonst einmal kommentieren was man
damit alles gravieren kann weil im video
wurden halt auf süßigkeiten brote
gummibärchen und so graviert okay leute
jetzt wird ein glaub mir dieser tisch
gehört alex naja also schaut mal hier
hier steht jetzt wenigstens drin das ist
mein tisch ist ich hab' holz ausgewählt
ich habe alles gemacht schaut mal hier
dieser tisch gehört alex okay da weiß
mein papa ist auf jeden fall bescheid
leute ich habe jetzt erst eineinhalb
stunden gelasert mit ganz ganz wenig
erfolg aber leute ihr könnt auch
wiedersehen beim toastbrot passiert nach
wie vor nichts und jetzt geht es wieder
ab hier aber dass ich bin dumm hier das
beschreibt das video auf jeden fall ganz
gut weil das wäre ein bisschen schade
gewesen könnte man nur so kleine sachen
gravieren
jetzt habe ich halt auch einen dicken
schriftzug darauf berlin willst du die
kartoffeln haben hier besteht mein name
probieren und dies unfassbar lecker ja
ja ja leute also was soll ich sagen ich
habe mein bestes gegeben der mini laser
ist für mich jetzt nicht so dass mega
gadget also 300 euro würde ich dafür
safe nicht bezahlen ich habe mir halt
leider ein bisschen mehr erhofft aber
trotzdem ist es glaube ich ganz cool
dass wir jetzt öfter das teuerste aus
irgendeiner amazon kategorie bestellen
deswegen kommentiert super gerne mit
irgendeiner kategorie und vielleicht ist
euer kommentar dann im nächsten video
und wir bestellen dort das teuerste und
testen ist dann halt tristan abonniert
den kanal was mir nach oben da würde
mich sehr freuen
für mich geht's morgen in urlaub aber
das kommt ein geiles video worauf ihr
euch freuen könnt ich werde nämlich eine
woche von einem ersteigerten koffer
leben folgt mir sogar gerne auf
instagram und wir sehen uns sonntag
wieder gibt es viele leute